this video is sponsored by skillshare do
you like movies do you like games books
paintings you know what all of these
have in common they're art and they're
all made by people like you and me if
you've ever wanted to explore your
creative side then allow me to recommend
to you skillshare it's an online
learning community with literally
thousands of classes on anything art
related from acting to writing to making
videos on instagram like this class that
i'm currently taking from halley's
nerves all of these videos are curated
specifically for you to learn how to
inspire your own creativity so you never
have to worry about ads or anything like
that in the videos if you're interested
in taking a step in the right direction
then please check out that link in the
description below the first 1000 people
to click on it will get a one month free
trial of skillshare's premium membership
so you can explore your creativity today
and now on to the video
hi everyone abandoned here and welcome
[Music]
oh don't mind that someone probably just
got murdered outside my room or
something it is the spooky month after
all which means that spooky things are
bound to happen to everyone
eventually
it's
just
a matter of time really but you know
what else is happening this month
besides serial killers and monsters the
nintendo 64 online expansion service
pack which was definitely very scary
when we all saw its price tag i was one
of the many people in my generation who
are too old to be considered kids and
too young to be considered adults who
grew up with the original console
now there were lots and lots of happy
family-friendly fun games to be had on
this old gal
but there were also plenty of quite
creepy experiences to be had as well at
least they were when i was a kid with
you know kid brain and kid
voice
for real though when i was a kid my
voice was very high like super high you
wouldn't even believe it there was this
girl i really liked and whenever i so in
this video i'm going to go over the
scariest moments that i can remember
from my childhood playing games on this
very console right here and since this
is my personal list from my personal
real experiences from my real little boy
childhood be sure to share your
experience in the comments below if they
didn't show up in my list and if you're
still breathing of course
now you're gonna have to remember that
back in the good old nintendo 64 days
not only was i a small child with small
child brain
and voice but there was also no real way
for kids like me to look up guides on
the internet for these video games that
we loved to play unless of course your
parents felt nice enough to buy the
extra physical game guide from gamestop
or something like that which never
really happened for me and i didn't have
any friends to talk to about the games
so all of the games on this list like i
mentioned are my actual experiences from
my actual childhood that i experienced
genuinely and alone or maybe with my
brother or sister or both sitting nearby
that being said though what kind of a
nintendo 64 themed video would this be
if i didn't bring up super mario 64. now
i know what you're thinking super mario
64. it's so family friendly it's got the
wahoos and the yahoos and the mamma mias
and it is family friendly for the most
part but you see once you get 12 power
stars in the game a big boo appears in
the courtyard of princess peach's castle
if you take mario and punch the big boo
you get access to a whole new world
called the big boo haunt and let me tell
you it's pretty haunted you enter this
world and immediately you realize you're
not in kansas anymore you see this
haunted mansion in front of you and this
creepy music starts to play immediately
now this was already pretty spooky as a
kid but it wasn't too terribly bad since
you know it's a mario game and most
things in mario games have that certain
level of mario cuteness to it so i
wasn't too scared and i was actually
able to explore around the mansion and
things like that and i was fine until i
got to a certain room that is the piano
room now i'm a pianist i have been since
i was three years old so for me
personally i saw this piano and thought
to myself immediately oh my god i wonder
if i can run up to this and play a
couple notes and so i walked over to it
and just as i got close enough to touch
the keys and reach my hand out
the thing came alive with teeth and
force and verve there's no mario
cuteness to be seen in a living piano
monster that's trying to eat your face
off of course something like this
wouldn't scare me nowadays
of course
but when i was a kid this was probably
the biggest and scariest jump scare
moment that i had ever experienced up to
that point and it still seared into my
mind to this day
once again what kind of nintendo 64
themed video would this be if i didn't
mention
the legend of zelda ocarina of time
which just happens to be my favorite
game of all time
and for those who have played it you
probably remember that the entire game
is full of some pretty creepy moments a
lot of which could probably have a place
on this list if i'm being honest from
creepy dungeons to just characters in
general but instead of taking up a bunch
of different spaces on this list
pointing out the many different creepy
moments in the game i'm going to limit
placements in this list to one per game
which would logically be the scariest
moment from that game so in my opinion
the scariest moment of all the scary
moments in ocarina of time would be
that giant ball that rolls around trying
to flatten you when you're trying to get
your cockery sword in the forest whereas
a kid i mean you enter this little
corridor and you never know where that
thing's gonna come from right is it
gonna come from the left is it gonna
come from the right
you don't know
i'm just kidding you guys it's the dead
hand of course it's the dead hand you
knew it was gonna be the dead hand but
i'm talking specifically the dead hand
that you fight when you're a kid the
first time at the bottom of the well not
with the master sword but with that
little envelope opener knife excuse of a
blade thing that you have to use as a
kid there's just something about that
first encounter that makes you feel so
helpless and i think it mostly has to do
with the fact that there's this big
naked bloody long necked skull
skull-faced
stump-armed monsters sludging through
the skulls that make up the floors and
the walls towards you slowly trying to
eat your face off
and you're a kid you see what i mean
it's disturbing in the way that scars
you for life i mean i still see it
sometimes in my room as i'm trying to
sleep as its long dead hands
grab me from around the sides of my bed
and hold me and i can't move or breathe
and i see it in the corner of my room
with its neck pointed in the air
trudging slowly towards me and as it
leans down and i look into its dead
hollow eyes i wake up and i know that it
wasn't real
right
up next we have banjo-tooie which is the
sequel to the largely beloved
banjo-kazooie and starts off with some
scary intense moments right off the bat
you start the game get back into the
swing of things with reintroducing
yourself to the characters playing a
card game like banjo and kazooie and
mumbo and bottles but then an earthquake
happens mumbo investigates and sees that
gruntilda the witch has come back from
the dead and she always used to creep me
out anyway as a kid anyway mumbo rushes
back to the party all the while the
witches are shooting at him trying to
kill him he's able to get back to all
the others and warns them about what he
saw but the witches followed him all the
way back to the house and decide to
shoot and obliterate the building with
bottles still inside which kills him
literally kills him right off the bat
but it gets worse you play as the banjo
duo for a little bit and go see king
jingling who has a pleasant conversation
with you and asks you politely to fetch
the rest of his citizens of his kingdom
in exchange for jiggies one of which he
gives you upfront as payment what a nice
guy you're thinking and the duo walks
out of the palace commenting just that
but then we see gruntilda and her
sisters firing the bob machine which is
a life sucking machine at the palace
where you just were sucking the life out
of king jingling's palace and himself
and his little pet on the couch simply
because he talked to you a few minutes
prior and if you go back inside to see
the king again he's a walking
lifeless corpse a zombie and even his
little pet has been disintegrated to
nothing but some eyeballs that blink at
you on the couch you can walk around but
all you hear is him moaning and groaning
as he wanders around the place trying to
kill you whenever he gets up to you this
scary moment absolutely terrified me as
a kid you know before society was
desensitized to zombies because of the
billion movies and games there are about
them these days
[Music]
[Music]
not only did donkey kong 64 change the
world of rap forever it also gave me one
of the first auditory only scary moments
of my entire life and let me tell you
when you hear something scary but don't
see anything that almost makes it worse
tell me about it in the angry aztec
level in the game there's this area
that's a temple with five doors and five
golden bananas inside one for each kong
that's only attainable by that
respective kong now this area is already
kind of ominous with the closed
corridors and low not
and if available don't get out of the
temple and that timer hits zero you get
shot and killed no questions asked i had
literally no idea that the scary moment
was going to happen the first couple
times that i played it as a kid and when
it did happen to me i'm pretty sure a
piece of me died inside and it's still
dead just so you know
you know what's cool spaceships you know
what's also cool foxes what if i told
you that i used to play a game where
there were foxes in spaceships
star fox 64 is responsible for giving me
a love of fast-paced flying action
shooters so basically just star fox
games and helped to hone my gamer skills
a little hey that game was hard and i
beat it as a kid but anyway the game
itself really isn't that scary at all
throughout the course of the entire
thing the vast majority of the game is
just good old action space shooting in
space but when you make it to the end of
the game you face the final boss of the
game dr andross the evil scientist
himself so you show up no big deal like
all the other stuff before there's a
giant monkey head in front of you and
you just shoot it to death you're
shooting him you're shooting him you're
shooting him and then all of a sudden he
starts blowing up and you're thinking to
yourself hey i did it i'm pretty good at
this game how about the what the hell is
that his brain and eyes pop out and fly
around and try to kill you it might not
be the most scary thing in the world
anymore all right but as a kid
that creeped me the hell out to be joked
at at the last moment right when you
thought you won by this floating brain
and these creepy eyes that never blinked
just staring right into your soul
yeah that was a scary moment last on my
list but definitely not the least is a
return to the legend of zelda majora's
mask
i mean come on what kind of a nintendo
60 no what kind of a creepy gaming video
would this be if i didn't mention what
was potentially the most creepy and the
most depressing game of all time
majora's mask and on that note again the
game is chock full of creepy moments
from the start of the game pretty much
there's that sad looking strange tree
there's the father that's a zombie
trapped inside the cabinet there's even
the intense glare of the majora's mask
itself which i still find very hard to
just stare into but like i said with
ocarina of time i'm only going to focus
on what i felt was the scariest moment
from the entire game for this list in my
opinion out of everything the game has
to offer as far as scares are concerned
the scariest and most disturbing part of
the entire thing comes from a place
called icona valley you see in that
valley there's a song that you're taught
after you defeat the long dead skeleton
king of ikana the song allows you to
create empty soulless statue duplicates
of yourself and it's called the elegy of
emptiness now i get it there's a lot of
people out there that say that that
eerily smiling link statue is not really
creepy or not really smiling but like i
said these kinds of things affect
everyone differently and all i'm saying
is that if you saw that in the corner of
your room across from your bed in the
middle of the night almost completely
encompassed by the shadows with just a
little bit of light revealing the facial
expressions and it was just
watching you
i'd wager that you might experience what
the rest of us call a bit of a fright
and if not well you might be empty
inside not unlike the elegy of emptiness
statues the empty link elegy of
emptiness statue has creeped people out
for decades and even led to one of the
most famous creepypastas being made ben
drowned so clearly i'm not alone in this
also i made a theory about this in the
last video it's creepy it's fun go check
it out i'll link to it in the
description below
anyway that's the list i know it was
kind of short it had like what only six
scary moments but listen that's just
because they were my actual personal
scary moments that i could remember from
my memory at the time of scripting this
video i didn't look them up on the
internet to fill out some sort of
fabricated list like some sort of
youtuber
but that being said of course i'm sure
many of you have different scary
experiences from the old gal so be sure
to let me know what they is down in the
comments below given that you're still
alive right now also thank you so much
for watching also like this vid if you
liked this vid also subscribe to stick
around for so much more also
huge thanks to my bandit crew who make
my day every day and are the reason why
i can make silly videos like this one
hallelujah now
i've got to do something creepy to end
this video
but what to do
what to do
oh
i've got just the thing
[Laughter]
[Music]